purge magazine
that's some of what's ahead on our
program schedule
[Music]
this week on book notes our guest is
anthony cave brown former correspondent
for the london daily mail he joins us to
discuss his recent book treason in the
blood h saint john philby kim philby and
the spy case of the century
[Music]
anthony k brown who was saint john
philby
he was kim kilby's father the
uh
a character in the in this book in his
own right um
he was
recruited at an earlier age into a very
privileged elite class um
the indian civil service to rule the
indian
subcontinent
um went out to punjab became
disenchanted
with the raj
and um
as it was known
and
entered into the service of
king ibn saud over saudi arabia
um
let me interrupt the picture that we're
showing st john philby is the older man
john philby was much older in that
photograph
but in his younger years he was very
much like kim phill be his son standing
right now standing right next to him yes
go back to what you said
uh
all these little terms what was the raj
mirage was the an indian term for the
body of laws by which the indians govern
themselves and gradually it became the
um
the appellation for um uh uh the in the
britons who ruled uh india during the uh
uh at around about the turn of the
century where was saint john philby born
uh saint john philby was born in salon
uh then the part of the british empire
very typically uh english
ruling class family military background
senior military
appointments
um
and uh one of the columnists
who went out to
build the
coffee industry in salon at the turn of
the century um
they were an upper middle-class family
of um
repute
danish origin going back to the 16th
century
um
and much admired in the
the quarters in through which they moved
um
what years did he live what st john
philby yes he was born in 18
1885 and he died in
1960 in beirut
and
just a quick capsule of during his
lifetime what did he become
uh in the service of the british
government overseas he became in turn a
revenue assistant in punjab in india
he then went out to
what is now iraq during world war one to
become a political officer with um
the invading british armies in
iraq uh he was then detached from the
political service in what was then
mesopotamia which is now iraq
um detached from there to go on a a
special mission
by camel across the arabian deserts to
a little-known arabian prince called ibn
saud
who was the
later became king of
saudi arabia
saint john fiore's mission there was to
arrange
for even south tribesmen over of whom
there were many thousands to rise um and
provide a flank guard to the advanced by
lawrence of arabia
uh in the advance on damascus and uh and
jerusalem what year is this this was
1917 1918 1919 in there as such he
became saint john fiore became
um second only to lawrence himself in
his prominence as an arabist
um
he returned to uh um
london at the end of the war i was then
appointed again as um minister of
internal security uh in the state of
iraq a term which was then
brand new and which went meant
in arabic the cliff
um
saint john philby was one of the people
who rapidly fell off that cliff um
he he found himself
disaffected seriously disaffected with
the british government and its various
policies towards the arab states and the
balfour declaration and that sort of
thing
um
but his career was saved
by winston churchill of all people who
um appointed him as political agent to
the first king
of the first state of uh jordan in other
words i think he must have been
king hussein's the present kings
a great
grandfather
he remained there in that appointment
until about 1926
when again
some of his disaffection began to show
itself
and he was found to have been in
unauthorized what they called
unauthorized uh correspondence with ibn
saud who
was still the ruler of what is now saudi
arabia
unauthorized correspondence carried with
it um
the connotation of espionage that is to
say that he was using the information
which um
he gained in the course of his post
um
his work for the british government
um he passed that information to um even
saud
uh immensely was then bent on becoming
the principal ruler in all
the middle east and he was very close to
success at that time
uh he'd already occupied the the holy
sit twin holy cities of mecca medina
and he was about to
march on the red sea port of virginia
in all those activities he was quite
vitally assisted
by
saint john philby who was able to
advise him about how far
that is even south how far eben salt
could go in occupying all arabia without
incur incurring the wrath of
the british government which was then
the principal power in the middle east
um
from that appointment he became what was
virtually uh principal uh advisor to ibn
saud in foreign affairs a post a
position that he enjoyed
um
for the next many years up until 1953
when eben sowed himself his great friend
um died they were in fact a very great
friend close personal friends and it's
very reminiscent their friendship is
very reminiscent of this business of
the uh what happens when the wise man
from the east meets the powerful and
titanic man from the west
it was quite a moving friendship in many
ways
let me uh ask you this overall question
if i'm
watching you talk about this book
i'm an american
what
of what value you're talking about a
world a lot of people don't understand
what's the what's the impact on america
of these two men the impact was this
that in 1934
even south's treasury was in danger of
going bankrupt
and he decided for the first time to
permit
infidels foreigners westerners into
saudi arabia
in order to prospect for the minerals
there there were huge quantities of king
solomon's mines were there there was a
huge um whole mountain ranges of uh
quite high grade um iron ore there was
also oil
um
king of and saud wanted to sell the oil
concessions but he was uncertain who he
should sell them to and under certain
amount of pressure
um he did agree to sell them to the
british government
however
um
saint john philby was
anxious as always to do his own
government in the eye
um
managed to
manage his affairs so that the oil
concession
went to the american company
standard oil of new jersey a standard
oil of california as it was then
subsequently of course that became the
arabian american oil company and as the
state department described that company
in some testimony
it was as it remains the richest
commercial prize in the history of the
planet
um
that
modest maneuver on the part of saint
john philby in regard to the oil
deposits in um
uh in arabia
uh brought
revenues worth trillions to this country
and as they say in oil circles it made
america rich or perhaps richer
by the way where are you from
uh well i'm a britain i was born in
britain
and where do you live now and i live in
virginia um and have done since 1975 i
think but getting old for
how long is that 1975 to the present day
what have you done over the years i've
been doing books i've this is my tenth
book
um
and um
almost all on the same type of subject
what's that what's the the bodyguard of
lies bodyguard lies is that an account
of the all the intelligence operations
which went into
um
the um
d-day operation in normandy on the 6th
of june of 1944.
um
it was that book that brought me to
washington in the first place or
although i've been here as a
correspondent on many occasions in the
past
ever since 1960 the cuban missile crisis
brought me here first of all what uh who
would you work for then as with the one
of the london dealers the daily mail in
london but the
the the the thing that caused me to take
up residence here was um the freedom of
information act which had just been
introduced when i was working on
bodyguard of lies
and i didn't
the title derives from one of uh
churchill's statements um in world war
ii
uh that truth is truth in war is so
precious she should always be protected
by a bodyguard of lies hence the title
um the principle
element in that book bodyguard of lies
was the
first of all i i
managed to obtain knowledge of and break
that story about the breaking of the
german codes um
ultra
um
which came from
a connection of mine here in washington
the other big thing was of course the
cover and deception plan for d-day
um the plan by which um
eisenhower was able to um
misinform and thereby outwit the mind of
hitler about where when and how we were
going to land a very important book
it's still a um it's regarded as i'm
glad to be able to say a classic these
days
uh then it was an authentic bestseller
this book
combines the story of saint john philby
and his son kim philby yes
has that ever been done before no
is there new information in this book
yes
where did i get it um
where does one ever get it you just
wander around in a disconsolate fashion
uh interviewing people until you finally
find the man that you've been looking
for all these years the reason i asked
that one of the things in one of your
notes in the back is that ruffina is
that the way he is
his fourth wife kim philby's fourth wife
showed you his un published memoirs or
some of papers that he has yes has that
ever been anybody ever written about
that before well they were sold just
recently by servers so to that extent
they are now in the public domain at the
time that i saw them which was
um 1990 and 1991 i was there twice in
moscow
um they had not been
they were not in the public domain at
that time and curious enough it was the
kgb the soviet intelligence service the
old soviet intelligence service their
officers which arranged the um the
meetings with uh rafinha
uh refugee
roofing of philby they went very well
for about and she in turn introduced me
to other um more of
pilbas colleagues in moscow
a very good connection indeed she made a
great fortune out of these things as you
probably know um when she sold them at
auction in sotheby's in london how much
i think about you in july of all
probably quarter million pounds around
about what um
100 000 which is a fortune by her
standards uh
we've got to get back to that eventually
but um kim philby what impact did he
have on the united states and who when
was when did he live
well he lived between 1912 um he was
born um
in british india
in the punjab um
and he died in
may of 1988 quite recently
in moscow
um
he was a chip off the old block very
much
his father's son
personally in the
in regard to his intellect which was an
extraordinarily uh polished and
developed brain
trained classically educated at trinity
college in cambridge which has got to be
one of the oldest universities or the
oldest colleges in the world
um uh
but at a very early age he became
addicted to um bolshevism
um
and um after some adventures in vienna
he was in fact recruited at the age i
think of
uh 19
19 or 20. he was recruited into the
soviet intelligence service as a secret
agent his job
um to penetrate the british secret
service at the highest levels
and it needs to be to spend his lifetime
doing so
um
kim's communism wasn't unknown in uh
in either oxford or cambridge
um
and he had great difficulty in
fulfilling his soviet mission and it did
so only in 1941 when
uh for reasons that are not clear the
british intelligence service did in fact
decide to employ him in a very important
position
we just recently broken the
the german intelligence services
um
ciphers codes
and this was providing us with
information about what was going on
inside germany on a very large scale
um
the area which he had uh was assigned to
was um the iberian peninsula spain
portugal spanish and the portuguese
empire
territories portuguese and spanish and
north africa where we were going to land
a very large number of troops the united
states great britain uh in 1942
so he control one of the active uh
theaters the place where uh
the intelligence service is made eyeball
to eyeball very dangerous place and his
job principal job was disinformation
this he was a master at um not a kind of
guy was he he was a
built very much like his father squat
but extremely attractive
very facile but not so facile that it
would lead you to suspect him of
anything
um
he was in many ways a master of
the art of acting
because he managed to uh conceal what he
really was which was a soviet secret
agent effectively for the next 40 years
40 years
without anybody really
ever catching a whiff of what his real
activities were and it was that that
made him so uh dangerous
he trained a whole entire generation the
earliest generation account foreign
counter espionage people
who came over from the united states
and thereby made some very important
contacts not the least of which was
james jesus angleton the the head of um
the um
who became head of the foreign counter
espionage service of which curious
enough aims
uh was a later member
aldre james aldridge yes
just now
this was a very important appointment
because
in due course he was sent as um
head of the british secret service in
the americas which meant that he covered
he was responsible for the service in
all its operations
uh in the western hemisphere
he was based here in washington
and it's one of the curiosities that
only a place where you go for lunch just
around the corner here
um
what's the name of that hotel hotel
bellevue the bellevue hotel yes right
across the street right across the
street that was the place where walter
kavitsky what the one person in the
united states who didn't know kim filled
his name and didn't know the truth about
his allegiances
uh was murdered
in 1941 not yet early 1942 who was he
water kavitsky was one of stalin's sort
of
super agents um super spies but overseas
and he had defected to the united states
in about 19 time the great purges in
about 1938.
um
kavitsky was giving evidence
about the identifications of soviet
agents in the west up here on the hill
um
and it was feared that the russians
evidently feared that he would name
these the cambridge five amongst others
so his was another one i gather that was
being brooded about at the time well
kravitzki spent the night in that
bellevue hotel in room 421
next morning the chambermaid found him
uh shot dead in his bed
the
windows
of the building of the room were locked
from the inside and the door
was locked from the inside
so of course great thought was given
about how it was that the assassin got
into the room
and how he got out of the room locking
the doors from the inside that has never
been figured out by the fbi or anybody
else the fbi was called in and so was
the
the the washington police so these were
as you can see the
the russians were quite prepared to
employ murder um
assassination in a foreign capital an
allied capital in order to protect the
identity of these particular agents
you mentioned uh
alger hiss also you mentioned in your
book
that uh
again another whitaker chambers
connection
that uh was it kravitsky that stayed at
the farm
no that was kravitzka's wife
it stated whitaker chambers farm up here
in maryland that's right um she took
sanctuary there uh after her husband's
assassination
and there were curious connections which
were never really proven or understood
down in um berryville and sort of the
the virginia area
but the uh
the importance of that bellevue um
that bellevue up uh murder operation it
was very great at the time because we
brought the british brought british
intelligence services brought kravitski
to london
um
to what is known as debrief him to
try and establish what it was that he
knew and he did in fact identify
one of philby's colleagues
um
mclean donald mclean sort of
semi-identified him and identified
various others he was then sent back to
this country by the british
uh in a submarine curiosity enough
and it was on the morrow
of his arrival in this country uh that
he was executed by the
the these gunmen who got into the room
at the bellevue hotel
so that's where you lunch my friend and
um
um not every day
a great while but you know another thing
you learned early in uh
your book is that this little book
that you can now buy for about 395 in a
bookstore uh has something to do with
where kim phillip got his name yes the
rudyard kipling's kim uh was one of the
most infectious novels of its time
perhaps the most infectious it it
produced um
the notion of complete loyalty to the
crown
the
young officer on the frontiers of the
empire
serving india and england for the common
good as it was regarded kim became very
famous and and
affected infected an entire generation
of young englishmen
um
with these notions uh it's an
extraordinarily romantic story and
beautifully written of course because
it's uh it is by rajat kipling
um and kim whose real name was harold
adrian russell filby
his father nicknamed him kim
um it appears that st john philby was
quite close to rudyard kipling
uh and certainly uh they also grew up
and worked in the same area lahore in in
in the punjab
kim became first kimbo
when he was born and then kim
and that appellation state stayed with
him for life um
throughout the british secret service
throughout
his association with what what is now
the central intelligence agency
uh throughout his um intelligence
operations um
on behalf of um
the british the american and the russian
government simultaneously in in the the
in the middle east
he became known to
all as kim
when he reached moscow he became known
to semi chastise the head of the soviet
intelligence service as keem
and he went to his name and went to his
grave keem philby
um
really has a uh
such a nickname
uh attached itself to a man of his uh
distinction for life
because he was distinguished in the
peculiar way that spies sometimes
acquire distinction you were
write this a big book this book bill uh
how long it'll take you to write it
oh
you know i signed the contracts in
october of 88. um
i started work almost immediately but
i've been living with it for some
considerable time beforehand because i
did the
biography of um philby's
boss the
legendary stuart menses ming is
churchill spymaster so i've been living
with it through that time i'd worked
with phil b
in between 58 and 63 and um now 62
in beirut so i knew a great deal about
this man
did you ever meet him by the way yes i
did i worked with him very closely you
worked with him oh yes uh in the great
capitals of arabia and middle east and
that sort of with kim philbin oh yeah
for how long
well i went ashore with the us marines
in in the lebanon in
in 1958 um and there he was he's well
known to us all there he was sitting
there at the um on the terrace of the st
george hotel
drinking his vodka and v8 so we all went
to see him because of course he was a
great authority
greatest living authority perhaps in
many ways on the politics of the middle
east this talent he's required from his
father who was his father was still
alive in fifteen still alive at that
time and lived in lebanon lived in
lebanon in exile from saudi arabia he
defended the saudis as one can easily do
in 1958 did anybody
in public know that kim philby was a
double agent or did they know did he
have a public profile in 58 yes very
uh you know in this country
yes
in the middle east we used to see him
every day
more or less in this country his name
was known to the people that had whose
business it was to know these things
uh he had already been publicly
exonerated of the charge that he um was
a soviet secret agent um by the
uh the foreign secretary
then harold mcmillan
in the house of commons
an allegation had been made against him
that he was in fact implicated in other
espionage matters and so
uh
the british government found it
necessary to exonerate him and then
promptly re-employed him in the british
intelligence service in beirut i mean
there was a case that i read in your
book that harold mcmillan stood up on
the floor of the commons and exonerated
philby from being a spy yes a soviet spy
and and after yeah he didn't exonerate
him from having been a burst by i mean i
don't think
uh he would go that far
however um
uh he was quite he it is not clear that
anybody really understood either in
washington or in london where kim
philbis loyalties really lay
he was regarded as being not quite at
this stage in his life not quite lilly
white
as they used to say in the cia now how
much personal interaction did you have
with him when he was alive oh i was of
another generation much younger man um
he was a terrible in many ways a snob
but a terrific snob so that i wasn't
quite at the same class i wasn't at
trinity college he was
cambridge at cambridge
but amongst his contemporaries um
they had very close interaction
um
the cia kept lists of um
of those people that were with whom he
was closely connected and one of those
lists came into my possession i quoted
in the book where all the people they
were all of exactly the same grouping
social grouping and the same um
uh so yeah social grouping and uh
age particularly he was very conscious
of the fact that i might be a watcher uh
uh street eyes uh as they used to call
people who um watch kim philby
younger members of the british
intelligence service how many times was
he married
uh
he might have been used to us
he married um
well
he entered into a relationship with um
an english county uh woman of some um
of good birth and good background as he
used to say but he didn't he
she bought him four children but he
didn't marry her for some reason or
other connected with the soviet service
until
uh long after the war when he was almost
forced to marry her
uh by the possibility that he might be
exposed
um to the british service as having
soviet um
connections let me just show the
audience these two pictures the one up
on top is of
that's um the the viennese girl that he
married in order to give her the
protection of his passport and also it
was she that
arranged affair so that he met his
recruiting officer um in the in the
soviet intelligence service she was a
young austrian uh communist i went down
here and this was
his um
common-law wife aileen
who used to write the hounds of
extremely well-known
very prominent family
he married her in order to give him the
protection he felt she could provide to
him as cover
in the british service
they did not marry although she born
four children they did not marry
until uh quite late
as i recall it was around about
1949 or so that they got married and um
they did so only because people were
becoming aware of the fact that she was
his mistress rather than his wife
and he had four illegitimate sons by her
so it felt prudent
the the two of them should marry
you right as i started to say earlier uh
you know one of the things when you i
want to ask you this as i read it i kept
trying to
follow the path through all this did you
ever get lost in this thing yes many
times so it's not unusual when you're
reading this to say hold on you've got
another couple chapters to go before you
figure this out first of all you're
dealing with a huge campus i mean it
starts in 1885 and it goes through to uh
1988 when um
uh philby finally died um
that's the point one you've got two
world wars
you've got an enormous
political development such as the
russian revolution up to a point
um
you've got
the whole question of the early years of
the cold war
you've got the whole question of the
development of the cia as a instrument
of world power
and then you've got finally the uh the
the british loss of
um
of the middle east
partially at least through what kim had
to tell the kgb
um
they've always claimed that his
dispatches to them were of the highest
importance politically so it seems
reasonable to suppose that
he was pretty pretty much aware of all
the joint anglo-american policy
decisions in regard to military and
economic
political operations in the middle east
again he ended up dying in moscow but
how many uh years did he live his last
years well he um he vanished from beirut
they were going to arrest him or there
were signs that he was going to be
arrested he vanished
in january of 1963
and he did banish nobody knew quite
where he was for the coming six or eight
months when he did surface in
moscow and made a statement um
about the reasons why he had
betrayed a generation as it was known at
the time
um
that was in july of
1963 and in that same year
very little was heard of him again for
25 years during that period he was in
serving in the soviet intelligence
service so for 25 years in moscow you
didn't we didn't hear very little
there was mutterings and sputterings and
um
things of that description for quite a
long time
but nothing which enabled anyone to get
a picture of how this man was living
what his work was or anything like that
he was in fact the authentic um
uh soviet secret agent at work in the
lubyanka in moscow that's deliberately
the headquarters of the soviet uh
service now you talk a lot about uh
pushkin square yes where is that pushkin
square was you know sort of equidistant
between the lupi anchor which is near
the kremlin
at his residence which was at a place
called patriarch's pond in moscow we
subsequently found out where it was he
was living and how he was living did you
go there yes many times i mean that's
where i did all my interviews with um
i spent about two weeks there i suppose
in his
apartment there
who's still living connected with the
philby name
well
he's got
to my certain knowledge he has two
sisters and they're still about but i
think they've changed their names in any
case i made no attempt to see them
because
while it might have been desirable that
i did so first of all i couldn't find
them but more particularly um
the the whole question of the philby
case the philby affair
uh the spy case of the century as it was
known in at the time
um
shattered that family to such a degree
that i felt that um it would be more
compassionate if i lay off them i knew
what i wanted to know and that was the
end of the affair then of course there
was kim philbi's own children
he had five
one of whom incidentally was married it
was named after
george washington
the
american president
um
harry
george philby was so named
after harry truman
and um
george washington
keeping the paper
the reason was you know what he was a
high-ranking british official in this
country
um kim philby kim philby was yeah for
how many years
oh not very long about sort of uh
20 months something of that order he was
signed to the embassy here it was he was
first secretary of the embassy here and
his actual job
was to um
liaise between the british intelligence
service which was then appropriately
important thing
and the um
and the cia which was then forming what
years again this was 1949 1950 and 1951
a bit of 95 of 1951
and he felt that you know since his
newborn boy um
might be appropriate to um
to name him as a tribute to um
two of america's most illustrious
presidents
uh he did that at his father's
suggestion by the way and father wrote
to him and said you really ought to call
uh the boy uh george washington bilby
well he thought that was going too far
so he called him harry
uh george will be let me ask you about a
a couple of little things because uh
yeah time moves so fast graham green
here's a picture of
kim philbin graham green green uh where
was this taken that was taken in
patriarchs the house in patriarchs pond
um
uh green on the left on the green on the
left uh philby on the right on the
occasion of uh
um
sorry a graham green state visit to uh
russia he was very popular with the
soviet government and where where was
graham green from
well he was um in the british secret
service he was an englishman
uh he was a rising young novelist at the
outbreak of world war ii he became very
closely attached with um
uh to kim philby and kim philby to him
nobody's completely sure
um where that
affection developed how
and how long it really lasted
politically sympathetic yes oh very much
so yes
graham greene was very hostile to the uh
some of the uh policies of this country
uh at around about the time of
mccarthyism and then into the vietnam
war he was because that was where the
the um the quiet american the character
that he invented in the vietnam vietnam
war arose um
was his observations in regard to a
certain american diplomat in um saigon
during that war
um
there's other little things the third
man
there were you you keep referring to
whether or not kim philby was the third
year what does that mean well
kim philby had uh recruited two
of his colleagues at uh
at cambridge one was guy burgess
um
the other one was uh
donald mcclain
both
became important soviet uh secret agents
and the job the the object behind the
the this
soviet uh
uh
development of these men was that they
would rise
uh
from these
exquisite college uh colleges
into the upper reaches of the british
civil service
uh they would enter the foreign office
they would become
ambassadors knights of the realm lords
peers
all that sort of thing all the while uh
being soviet secret agents there were
five such men altogether
of whom burgess
was
more important than they supposed
donna mcclain was clearly a vital
because he was cheaper he became chief
of the american desk at the foreign
office in london mclean and burgess had
a relationship
mclean
and burgess had a relationship yes they
did
um
they were
brought together through a curious sort
of secret society in cambridge called
the apostles
um
and had much to do with each other then
and with lord rothschild
uh
the heir to the banking fortune
um and kim pilby and uh
st john philby
and and indeed the whole uh of the
higher um
um
levels of the foreign office um where in
some way or another connected with the
this group of five
they'd all been educated together they'd
grown up together they'd come to high
places together they taught the same
world wars together they had much the
same
political and social um
attitudes why did they turn against
their country
combination
of youthful idealism it was quite
commonplace in those days for um
young britons of privileged birth to
become
communists
um
later
but once having become a soviet secret
agent it was a job not just for a
weekend or for
a month or even for a year but for life
you were committed um and if you
sought to
redefect to return to um
um
the courses of britain or the united
states or wherever it was the chances
were that you would either be liquidated
as was kravitzki around the corner here
or
your employers would be informed about
your activities during the last 10 20 or
30 years or whatever it was which could
often lead or could quite easily lead to
a jail sentences things that description
but once they got their tentacles into
you were finished
uh if you tried
to act in in any independent way
um what did happen
you've touched upon these things are
almost theological in their complexity
and i try to keep them simple
but it's no more possible for me to um
keep them simple in my conversation with
you than it is uh in writing this book
that's why it took so long
uh four and a half years of trying to
simplify and make uh sense of
uh a matter of almost theological
complexity you must remember you were
dealing with
a situation which is very much like the
religious wars of the 16th 17th
centuries
that
that collision between capitalism and
the in the west and communism in the
east
but you then in the
fairly in the middle of the book start
the discussion about james jesus
angleton that we showed earlier and it's
a face a matter of fact i showed one
picture i want to get the one that was
taken over in south kensington and uh
in london and that uh
kim philby had a tremendous impact on
his life yes
tell us more i think it's true to say
that phil destroyed uh angleton the
angleton's existence angleton was the
son of a
um a wealthy
um
american
spanish
medical proverb
spanish mother
who uh joined the
the old office of strategic services
that was the predecessor to the central
intelligence agency
uh during world war ii went to london
was trained by philby in the arts and
crafts of
um
counter espionage in the iberian
peninsula
he was admitted to what was virtually a
brotherhood this whole group of men
became a brotherhood simply because they
had
uh acquired the ability to read the
german supreme command's ciphers
that ability was political power on a
scale which most people had never
experienced before and it had
unlikely to have experienced again
uh secret intelligence is political
power
on the grand scale and so um
angleton joined the club
they become became great friends how far
that friendship went and what it
entailed
is anybody's guess did mr angleton ever
write about it never
uh did he die he died a year to the day
before philby did did you talk to him i
did a great length yes did he tell you
what the relationship was um
he did tell me but i'm afraid i forgot
all about it because it was a drinking
session in the madison hotel around the
corner here
uh
he was a huge and heavy drinker
here too was in a way was a classicist a
yali
um
so that he had much in common with
philby's peculiarities the film philby's
turn of mine
and what we cannot establish
this is where it starts to get
that theological complexity of which i
complained before
uh what we can't establish is how much
anger angleton knew about kim
philbis
loyalties
um
was mr angleton loyal to this country
there again
we can't be sure
is that where you are controversial on
all of us very
i
angleton was
investigated by internally by the
central intelligence agency at a very
high level
um
there were three investigations one to
establish um
the nature of the operations that he ran
within the counter espionage
department of the central intelligence
agency the art department into which
aims went albert james yes explain who
he was for those well he's the man who's
just recently been found to have been a
soviet uh secret agent himself the
biggest in history of america no
yes and no who can really assess these
things the problem with the ames case is
that it was he was entirely venal that
unlike these fellas all this this was
all ideological you know it was like a
religion of faith
a belief that
was implanted to youth and stayed with
them for life in many cases the problem
about angleton is this he was
investigated
a very high level investigations went on
the for a period of about eight years
one to establish whether he was himself
a secret a soviet secret agent two um
whether
how he ran his department and the
objectives and policies that he pursued
within that department
and the third one was a a history
of the activities of angleton and the
counter-edge
espionage department of the cia
all by
done by men who
are
who are expert in that particular arcane
uh byzantine activity
uh they were all retirees
they were all brought in from the
outside so they couldn't be contaminated
by this glutinous massive
of
affections and
relationships which grow up in that game
they sat down independently they arrived
at the conclusion one
that um
angleton was not a soviet secret agent
but can you imagine the effect that it
must have had on um uh angleton's
reputation when it was even suspected
that he might be a soviet secret agent
the second thing was wouldn't he be used
to this i mean that sensitive job no
you know
angleton was a pretty illustrious fellow
a pretty august
personality i mean
he was number three in the central
intelligence agency in many ways he
operated completely independently from
the rest of the institution was was the
ci director afraid of him
i can't tell you that i can't answer
that you'd have to ask mr helms helms
was his boss the most boss and patron
for most of his life
um
so that all in all
um when angleton was fired by william e
colby
um
he was fired for a minor case but behind
that lay a very serious matter indeed
and it was never it's never been finally
resolved
weather
angleton
was
completely loyal to this country they
did make one finding against him this
has never been revealed but
they did find that he'd acted in the
interest of
apparently in the interest of the soviet
union
over an important espionage his
knowledge of an important espionage case
in germany
uh one that had many repercussions uh
time though 1960 1970 and there
um but
as i've already explained to you you
know these matters get
terribly byzantine
uh and he who does not know all the
facts
you know poor average human being such
as myself
um he who does not know all the facts
shouldn't sit in judgment
there are games within games within
games within games and everything
embellished of course in a riddle let me
ask you though a couple quick things uh
what are your conclusions about a number
of things uh
is this country well served by its
intelligence intelligence community oh
brilliantly it took a long time to get
there but brilliantly said i mean in
other words as we sit here today this
the cia is a good operation in your
opinion yes i think it is um
i i think you've got your um
um share of classes
uh you know the sort of person that
should not be there
but most of those fellows really are um
high grade very high grade men
uh who devoted in themselves to the
secret service of their country and as
such usually are people of impeccable
bearing um did you ever serve the
british intelligence never no i've never
worked for intelligence
as a correspondent they used to ask me
to do a little spying for them you know
go and see the number of big pipe planes
on habaner airport in iraq or
ask president nasa this question or that
question
but
this was the limit of it we were all
approached in that sort of way at that
time but to be employed by the the
british intelligence service absolutely
not now where were you born
bath in somerset um
an old rather pretty uh georgian town
where did you go to school uh i went to
school in
luton uh a town in bedfordshire which
was quite close to my father's work at
that time
and
that was a grammar school it wasn't one
of the illustrious universities
are you still a british citizen yes you
tend to remain so i do how long do you
expect to live in the united states oh i
i married an american so um
this was in paris in 1978.
do you have a family children um
by a previous marriage how many kids too
and
when you are dealing with intelligence
like this do you get a lot of
unsolicited phone calls when people know
you're working on somebody's reputation
well i'm really not working on anybody's
reputation i'm working on a set of
historical facts you see secret
intelligence really is the obvious
side of um
ordinary day-to-day politics
it's the secret side of great events and
i'm not very much concerned with
people's uh reputations unless it
becomes necessary to do so as in this
case i've had to pay a lot of attention
uh to the uh conduct of office of people
like engleton
i never get any phone calls simply sorry
because i've got an unlisted number
um
and i don't think anybody really
believes that um
it's you know it's worthwhile giving me
strange calls and that sort of thing
what's the most effective tool that you
have then when you go after a book like
this and what i'm talking about was a
basic knowledge basic knowledge went
back of course to
since yes the basic knowledge went back
to the question of bodyguard of lies
um what year did you put that book out
that was 1975 the events which i
described were occurred in 1944
and i built up a a very wide range of
people engaged in political warfare
secret intelligence
that type of activity at that time and
that was the generation which handed on
the sword to the one
uh ones that like uh philby and uh
angleton became representative of did
kim philby
hurt his own country
britain or his own you know of course
that's the old question of
the value of espionage itself and did he
hurt the united states in any way yes
to the extent that um
it was grievous it was very very serious
indeed
he was in a position well let me go back
a minute alan dallas once said that um
to be effective a secret service must be
secret who is alan dallas alan dallas
was the director of central intelligence
agency at the time that philby was here
great friend of kim hilbert
so
philby knew the identities of all the
key officers in the cia and the british
intelligence services and the french and
the german and everybody else
um
who were about to fight the cold war
which gave the russians an immense
advantage from the start
the second thing is he knew what a great
deal about the codes and cyphers and
methods of signaling so the russians had
the job of uh intercepting that
those communications were
greatly um assisted by philby himself he
could they could see
at a time when world war three seemed to
be both him imminent and inevitable he
he was so in such a position that he
knew what we would do he was reading the
uh portions of the american war plans
the strategic air command war plans
um
the the the question the the early
formation of um of the formation of nato
and the rearmament of germany and japan
they who until recently have been
uh he was very closely acquainted with
all the
weft and warp of um
of
strategy tactics and policies as they
were at that time and as such
uh it could have been deadly um
had uh uh war broken out as was expected
in 1953 or it was estimated that world
war would break out 2015 in in 1953. you
write that uh general macarthur's uh
about his assertions that philby
as well as burgess and mclean that you
talked about yes the three in that group
had betrayed the plans and the order of
battle of the u.s eighth army in korea
to the communist intelligence services
and that 30 000 men had been killed
wounded or captured through that
betrayal yes
did i think that illustrates what i've
just said the whole question of um
in government
and especially in the aliens there are
one or two um positions which are of the
utmost
uh importance
where
the occupants of those desks read
everything from every side
and kim he'll be had that position
now the
relationship between the um
british government and the um
and the
united states government was extremely
close at that time we once again the
british were assisting on advising the
americans on the establishment of their
own
intelligence foreign intelligence and
security services
um
they were launching on a very large
scale
joint operations in all corners of the
globe against the soviet union
there was a great deal of war planning
we had
don't forget that at that time britain
had a very large navy it had the world's
second largest
air force uh second only to the
strategic air command uh
and um
the army um was a particular the the
army available was a particularly good
one which could be
deployed very rapidly in europe and the
middle east and that sort of thing
so that the intimacy
started by eisenhower and um
and fdr
had
the intimacy between those secret arms
of government had strayed over into
uh the truman administration
um
as late as 1949 there was still a
british military mission stationed
within the pentagon
to
arrange affairs should war break out or
to
engage in joint planning
now
phil we occupied that position
and he was still sitting there
with the stuff going across his desk um
um
when the korean war broke out
nobody could be quite sure at that time
whether this was going the opening shots
of world war iii it seemed very probable
that they were you must remember that
the united states the truman
declared a state of national emergency
when the chinese suddenly attacked
across uh into um uh korea as they did
uh late uh midway through that campaign
philby knew these things
um
he was in a position
to advise his soviet um
friends in uh washington
about the most in innermost uh um
decisions
um
of the two governments here in
washington as represented on the one
hand by the state department or the
the pentagon and on the other hand by
the british embassy or the british joint
staff mission
um
now i want to stress something about
that korean business whether
the information that he passed to the
russians resulted in the death
deaths of all these men
it's the opinion of dean rusk who was a
um
an eminent um
uh state department official of the
times it was that everything that was
known to the everything was decided in
the um
uh truman administration was made known
to the british government
um
in the person of the ambassador
up there on massachusetts avenue
and that in turn
found its way
very rapidly to the
um uh to the intelligent services of the
kremlin
they in turn passed it to peking
and the uh to the their
representatives in
north korea at that time
um
this has never been proven
uh it's much suspected and with every
justification but
william manchester who was macarthur's
biographer
um managed to contact philby in moscow
and place these questions before him
um
he'll be naturally denied that anything
he'd done while he was in office in
washington
uh in any way of course the
the destruction of the or the near
destruction of the us eighth army there
uh that he was responsible for the
deaths of thirty thousand fifty thousand
sixty thousand
um
these numbers are quite freely rooted
around but
um
in the end the conclusion was that
through philby
the soviet government learned enough
about the deployment the
limitations of of course the
lengths and breadths of the strategy in
korea
to be able to
launch the
chinese counter offensive at the right
place at the right time with the right
weight
uh and with terrible destructive force
if i were asked
if my
opinion was asked for and it often is on
this case i would say that philby did in
fact provide the soviets with that type
of information
at the end of your picture section you
have
a picture of
his fourth wife and the casket yeah in
1988.
in the end uh did kim philby believe
at the end in communism
and uh what kind of a send-off that's an
excellent question because
the the weird thing about uh ideological
warfare theology uh is that can a man
sustain it for life can he
um
maintain his the the beliefs of his
youth
right throughout uh his middle years um
to his deathbed and in the case of pilby
he did not to sustain his um conviction
that um
the bright uh ism of the future was
communism
um
he never turned against marxism
uh but he did turn against the soviet
form of communism and here again we
we meet the ultimate um
um
enigma
in the pilby case and that is who is he
working for at the end of his life
is there a movie in this book yes
when
well the united artists have got it um
they bought it even in manuscript form
um
um
so i imagine
um
daniel day lewis is supposed to be
taking the lead part and hugh white more
as doing the script
this is the book this is the cover
treason in the blood
the story of h
saint john philby and his son kim philby
by anthony k brown and we thank you very
much good to be here
[Music]
oh
[Music]
here's a book notes